come on John you are suffering from
suffer ating that's not a word you
appear to be suffering from a disease
known as siding psychosis which makes
you dress poorly and so I in
commiseration I'm also going to dress
poorly so this is my outfit today
weekend at Bernie's look going on I
would like to ask all of nerdfighteria
in commiseration with John Green and his
signing psychosis to dress porn and put
photographs of yourself on the internet
and tag them signing psychosis
preferably on tumblr or Twitter so that
we can seek them out and laugh at you
well how the hell did I get to Anaheim
I'm here because this is where we're
doing VidCon this year it's also where
they're doing Blizzcon this year and I
wanted to steal their ideas for how to
make conferences epic anyway I love them
we do things with nerdfighters like for
example where's stupid clothing which
I've stopped doing by the way because I
had to go out and public actually love
it when groups of nerdfighters get
together and do cool things without us
even knowing that it's happening for
example there is a group of people that
isn't working for nine months on an iOS
game well John and Hanks awesome
adventure that stars yes John and Hank
after John and I found out about the
project we actually emailed them to ask
if they needed anything from us and they
said yes we need one thing from you
your voices so when you kill that poop
shooting Nintendo with your wind turbine
that is actually my voice screaming holy
giraffe sex yeah these people think I'm
weird they also wanted to give us a cut
of the proceeds from the game which we
totally took and we are taking those
proceeds and putting them into a fund a
film's that I cannot talk about yet and
I just have to thank that he would
people that were working about product
for the last nine months on Adams who
put the whole project together Desiree
Chuck Ollie Aaron Billy Amy
Luke and Halle thank you all so much for
making this happen it's so fun and it's
a dollar ninety-nine Shannon or a zerg
being Zerg rush another good example of
a group of nerdfighters getting together
and doing something awesome the hundreds
of people who design covers for The
Fault in Our Stars that project in case
you're wondering contributed to to
really sort of revolutionary things
happen one convincing a publishing
company for the first time in history
note to put a book in bookstores with a
cover designed by fans of that book that
has just never happened and second
convincing penguin to take very
seriously the cover for the Fault in Our
Stars which they have done it's
interesting to me that so many
nerdfighters don't seem to like to cover
The Fault in Our Stars despite the fact
that it's only because of them that it
is so good if you don't like the cover
The Fault in Our Stars there's two
really good blog posts that you might
read one by karen kavett who's kind of
been the unofficial chief creative
officer for nerdfighteria for like years
and the other by the yeti who is john's
wife and is also a curator of a museum
of modern art here's my perspective this
is the kind of cover that publishing
companies give to books that they want
to become classics it's bold its iconic
it's like timeless it's like something
that's never gonna go out of style
someone who's actually read the book I
know that this is the cover of that book
help me I'm at bliss Corning in a limo
one last thing like a year ago I made a
video explaining how to make a.com
domain name website thing problem with
that video is that it cost like eighty
dollars to set up and a friend of mine
had some brain crack that he threw at me
to simplify the process and also to make
it cheaper so we wanted to do that we're
calling it the URL at ron and after some
months of working on it it's ready to
launch here's what it does it turns your
tumblr into a dot-com domain name and it
does it in like five minutes of work
with thirty dollars you also get like
custom email addresses it's good stuff
so if you're interested in that you can
go check it out at URL at Ron come John
congratulations on an amazing classic
book cover for what I think is going to
be an amazing classic book I'll see you
on Monday hello and welcome to the
tutorial guide thing for URL adronis
pretty freakin simple but in case you
had any questions here's how it works
there's no time to waste on your silly
little rats you must leave now hurry go
get in your pants
so I'm now in pants
[Music]